[Music]
hi welcome to episode number 111 of the
weekly Google cloud platform podcast I'm
mark meadow I'm here with my colleague
Melanie work how are you two doing there
hey Melanie
I'm having a good morning good morning
good afternoon
excellent so this week we have a very
special person Sam Ramsay a VP of
Product joining us for an interview
basically to talk about all things cloud
so pretty excited about that yes
yes a lot of oversight in terms of just
thinking about leadership and it's you
it's kind of Zen actually but yes before
we get into that as always we will talk
about the cool things the week and we
will also end with a question of the
week and our question of the week is
actually if you wanted to run or if
you're running a Google Hut function and
you wanted to run it daily or weekly or
hourly how would you do this if you
don't have cron ability in the cloud
function chat so we'll talk about that
but let's go ahead and talk about our
cool things of the week yeah so first
cool thing of the week comes from some
of our favorite friends over at CR e
customer reliability engineering this
week it's it's will Tipton site
reliability engineer under CRE they have
a really good blog post all the CRA ones
are amazing you should definitely read
them but they're talking about an
example escalation policy so basically
how to set up escalation policies for
your SRA teams around what happens when
the SRA can't bring the service back
into SLO either they need help stuff
like that how to set up what they call
thresholds and how to define them and
basically you know set up these sort of
procedures and situations so that people
know exactly what they should be doing
when and if they need more help above
and beyond what they can do themselves
it's a cool read it's good to understand
in terms of support especially so
another thing that we wanted to mention
for the week is that there's a cool fine
art doppelganger feature that's been
added to the Google arts and cultural
app and that's out there on iOS and
Android and so it's kind of a fun way to
search through existing paintings that
exist and see what's your doppelganger
painting and in the Google arts and
culture app is actually been around
since 2016 it's very useful in terms of
exploring different artwork that's out
there
and exploring what some museums and so
check it out I'm installing it right now
I know it's kind of fun it's some of the
examples that are already out there and
showing what people look like awesome
well I wouldn't be a week of the Google
cloud platform podcast if I didn't talk
about kubernetes many of you probably
noticed late last year 1.9 was announced
as available it hasn't hit gke yet but
the blog series that they do on a
regular basis whenever they do a new
release called the five days of
kubernetes has started for 1.9 they've
done the first I would say four one two
three four they talk about Windows
support which is gone beta incriminate
ease which is really cool storage the
CSI framework is an alpha a bunch of
stuff around dynamic admission controls
client goes so basically this stuff if
you want to do custom controllers and
you're in sort of some resource
definitions basically extend kubernetes
so we'll probably find at some point
some people to come in and talk to us
about this kind of stuff if anyone on
the kubernetes team is listening and
want to come join us we would love to
have you but if not definitely go check
out the five days of kubernetes they're
always a good read and we've also got
listed in there the kubernetes comic oh
my god is so great that is out there
that smooth sailing with kubernetes it's
a fun little comment that helps give you
an understanding of this space ya know I
love this if you've ever thought to
yourself I just don't quite get where
kubernetes or containers as a whole how
that works or why people use them or
what's like the impetus behind that kind
of stuff it's a really great
light-hearted way of looking at the
ecosystem and looking at why these
things exist and why people use them and
how they use them and it's just adorable
it is adorable and it's fun to see all
the different metaphors that they're
using throughout all right well I think
it's time to go talk to Sam let's go do
that so today I am both excited and
delighted to have Sam Ramsey here with
us VP of product management at Google
cloud platform so very happy to have you
here how you doing today Sam I'm doing
fantastic thank you Mark and thank you
money yeah thank you for the wine that
you bought that was very lovely it
seemed like only good manners yeah we
totally want to talk to you today about
sort of your thoughts about tech and
cloud and open source but for those
people who don't know who you are I'm
sure there aren't very many of those do
you want to tell us a little bit about
you and your history here at Google
cloud and what do you do sure so I've
been here for
total thirteen and a half months true
fact I just met somebody today who's
been here 13 and a half years exactly 12
times longer than me Wow and so I have
much to learn although I've learned as
much as I could in the intervening time
I've been in the industry about 23 years
this my family will tell you I'm not
good at really anything but software I
started programming when I was 9 in 1980
when they put in the Commodore pet 2001
ends into the Oakland Unified public
school district never thought of
programming as a career although I kind
of accidentally was the teacher's
assistant for AP Computer Science I'm
old enough that that was Pascal at the
time I just I did Pascal I didn't oh
yeah so that's that's that's kind of me
I'm fascinated by distributed systems
distributed cognition I have a CS degree
but it's not computer science it's
cognitive science from UC San Diego also
the home of Pascal strange coincidence
but it's artificial intelligence
neuroscience and then also things like
cognitive psychology linguistics I'm
just fascinated by how people think how
we think at scale how we think with each
other both the success cases in the
failure cases and that I think is so
much of what lights me up about cloud
computing about large scale you know
digital enablement it's about being
better and more interesting humans
together and starting to ask the
questions well what's possible now that
used to be impossible and how much
further can we go well and if you've got
this background with cognitive science
what do you think about what's going on
in the AI revolution that we're having
right now oh it's it's fascinating I
mean I don't know what the reverse of
Shaden for it is but I graduated in 1994
into the second AI winter right when the
promise of the I had been way over
promised and then it crashed and nobody
wanted to hire us right it's like kind
of go to the back of the hiring line now
we're in kind of the third AI summer
there's probably a third AI winter
coming I wouldn't be surprised if that's
happening but I also think that it won't
completely disappear because there's so
much that's been proven doubt but yes
it's nice to see where it's on an
upswing do you wish you could go back
and do more with it again you know it's
a ridiculous privilege to be at Google
because I'm surrounded by experts in all
of these fields so do it again yeah I
can do that
Tuesday true go talk to somebody from
Jeff Dean's team use some of our
internal tools
you know our new tensorflow automation
system and do the code lab right last
week I took a code keishon I took three
workdays to learn go and to do
kubernetes the hard way on GCE
Wow so this is a place where you just
kind of get to keep learning the one
thing I'll see is really different about
AI this time is that the scope and scale
of how it gets executed how it's
delivered and how it changes our
experience as humans means that we
really have to be awesome at ethics and
that's something that typically deep
science and ethics have always struggled
to get along social sciences humanities
and then hard sciences so-called it
would be really helpful for us to all
start to find ways to be more
multidisciplinary in our team structure
more diverse in our thinking so that we
can start to anticipate what's the
second third fourth order effects of
these that aren't obvious to the person
who created the tech so it is a major
change from 94 when I graduated yeah I
just didn't have this kind of power
agreed it's definitely a huge shift well
so how did you end up at Google that is
a great question I always admired Google
and I thought these consumer technology
that the company built were amazing
obviously you know from search to you
know I moved my entire prior startup
onto Google Docs actually those two
startups ago because it was just so
efficient again for collaborative
thinking right how do you look at what
people are thinking about in real time
the closest thing you can get is I was
typing the same document it performs so
well but I'm really a plumber
I like distributed systems and I've been
in distributed systems and enterprise
software since I don't know 1998 so
Google never had a place for me and so
at that sort of basic structural
mismatch
I never thought Google is a company I
don't want to work for it but then a
year and a half ago when I was the CEO
of Cloud Foundry which is the leading
open-source platform as-a-service
I started hearing who was at Google now
and what Google cared about and what
they were doing and I thought this is
becoming a place for plumbers we can
really get really excited about
middleware and we can start taking these
developer platforms and infrastructures
that Google has built for itself that
have scaled the business made it the
second most valuable company in the
world
and start to offer that out to have
company in the world and for me that's
speaking of ethics like it's kind of
where my ethics have always lain how do
we build tools that enable other people
to take care of what they care about so
I guess you're the VP of Product
Management what is like what is a day in
the life of a VP of Product Management
look like now that you're at Google well
it's pretty great first of all I think
one of the great things about Google is
it's a bit of a Montessori School so
there's an inversion of control the most
important person - or squirrels that the
student not the teacher and I think at
Google the most important people are the
people who are actually doing the work
not the managers and that's consistent
from what I've heard from Google culture
over the last 19 years so it doesn't
feel very much like oh you know I'm a
senior executive and thank goodness
because I was born in Berkeley and
raised in Oakland so I'm pretty anti
hierarchical and anti-authoritarian so a
day in the life email review some stuffs
get your mind blown because you know
Jeff Dean just did a talk at nips on how
you can create next generation you know
high performance computer indexes flying
machine learning and not classical data
structures deal with prioritization what
are we going to ship we're going to kind
of ship where do we apply the headcount
and then what's open-source strategy
mean or there's a lot of opinions on
that but how do we start to apply that
since open-source is so meaningful to us
and it's such scale but should we do
this or that and is that 10 engineers
your 20 and what's the opportunity cost
there and then hey how do we go and talk
about this right so we got a conference
schedule coming up for this year what
are we going to be ready to talk about
and how can we use other people's
heartbeats well to stay both on message
and empirical right what have we learned
in there for it we don't want to offer
you from our learning not theoretical
and certainly you know keeping it honest
and humble so it's a it's a pretty great
job I think any job has got its share of
horses and mucking out the stable right
you want to find the right balance very
true but we muck out stables cuz we love
horses so I think this is the place
where the things that I really care
about you know and the people that I
want to work with you know super nerdy
people who are like hey it makes you
more credible as an executive that
you're also a dungeon master I'm like
how many companies are like yeah of
course you played the Indian we all do
it's it's very acceptable here well so
in terms of it sounds very clear to me
why you know you've got your background
how you ended up definitely involved
into open source what do you miss about
Cloud Foundry I miss the interaction
with the board so it's interesting to be
a CEO in a company where you're
constructing working with senior vice
presidents CEOs of other companies who
really only have an hour or month to
hang out with you and they know that
we're all like going in the same way and
they expect you to make all of the
decisions right you've got the entire
scope you know if it fails it's your
fault if you succeeded it's the team but
like I never had a performance review
because it was either the company was
doing well or it wasn't and we needed to
adjust those things so there was no
there was no layer of ego right
everything was just a thing and so
getting into a mode where we start
managing and judging people and
justifying our existence as opposed to
going gosh I'm putting you know every
waking heartbeat into making this great
and we're all pretty good at this stuff
so let's get them some feedback on how
to tune but do we need to do
calibrations and all this stuff so it's
it's interesting to get back into a
large company because I was at Microsoft
in the 2000s at that point you know many
tens of thousands people when I left it
was 90,000 employees so you have to have
these systems in place but that shift
from constantly being in the doing to
also have to having to come back and
assess and sort of justify existence as
a it's an emotional adjustment so now
I'm actually kind of curious now that
you've come to Google and and I love
that metaphor of Montessori school I
think that's that's spot-on for how
Google is but that was given to me by a
friend that is that is what I'm but I'm
actually kind of curious like what's
been the most surprising thing for you
coming to work with Google a Google
cloud specifically God how nice people
are right I anticipated that a little
bit on the way in but it would be you
know I think it also surprised me based
on my prior sense of Google because you
know certainly for example before this
podcast it was very hard to understand
what Google people were like because the
company's ethos was like you'll
encounter us through our web interfaces
mm-hm and you know we can make up a lot
of stories like you know remote hard to
deal with superior maybe
and then you actually get into these
things like one of the things I get to
do as a product managers I get to do
product management for Eric Brewer right
the person who authored cap theorem and
like students in his classes invented
things like data bricks as a side
project amazingly cool
super humble like you're just
encountering everybody's sort of it the
first order of experience right you're
not encounter about themselves
you're encounter what everybody thinks
about the problems and that is just it's
a wonderful surprise and it catches me
off guard still every single day because
so much of the industry and my
experience hasn't been like that don't
you know who I am you know ladies and
gentleman this person doesn't know who
he is you know it's really nice to find
people who are just into the work no
matter what they've done and just moving
forward so really nice super smart
people with a lot of lot of emotional
intelligence and that's that's a
pleasure well clearly you've had very
little experience so I'm curious where
do you want to go with your career where
do you what gets you excited to learn
about to great questions
I think there's a great quote from the
founder of aikido which is a relatively
young martial art his name is Maura
Highway Shiba people call him Oh sensei
it's a true victory as victory over the
self so in terms of learning one of the
things that I want to continue to do is
look learn how can I be better right
there's some challenges around how do
you do scalable communication yeah I
speak from the heart got relatively good
values and ethics I can still make
mistakes in spoken language when I'm
talking with 500 people and somebody's
gonna get offended and that's harm and I
feel bad about that but I get the
feedback it's like okay I could I can do
better at that so a lot of the learning
is just how to how to take care of large
groups of people in communication and
understand how can I provide a little
bit of input and guidance that will open
up something useful to them that will
generally get us moving in a common
direction intense and difficult skill
and one that you can only learn when
you're in a position where that's your
job you can I can't do this in school
you're at the heart of it always
thinking of computing in some way shape
or form but that's the interesting thing
there's like rather than distributed
computation distributed cognition is
really interesting because
we're the people doing the cognate eight
you know the doing the cognitive work
right we're not just doing computation
there's emotional labor there's a bunch
of the other things going on so how do
we how do we do that so that's that's
the learning front I think in terms of
what I want to do like for the next
decade I would like to help Google take
what its reinvented in what we now call
DevOps and see I CD and you know sort of
next-generation static analysis
monitoring operations site reliability
engineering this whole sort of soup of
words what it is is a digital operating
model that has allowed Google to create
a great advertising business because it
can iterate everything about it many
times today I think we shipped a
production about nine thousand times a
day
but again not to get distracted by what
does it take to ship nine thousand times
a day but why would you do it because
you can be in this very tight feedback
loop where you're constantly learning
from your users and that's true
regardless of your industry we're in
search and ads Spotify zin music right
they are iterating their environment I
heard they shipped to production like
three thousand times a day Wow
so what is that digital opera model and
how do we make that real for the entire
world no matter how small of a company
how new you are to software how large of
a company how sophisticated you are how
do we take what we've learned and offer
that as a platform for the planet to you
know
compute how they might care to are
they're particularly like technical
products that like we have or
potentially may have in the future that
get you like really excited anything
you're particularly passionate about
right now oh boy I mean just pick one
just I was gonna say like clearly I'm
not a very passionate person I'm really
lucky I get to care about all the things
I'm doing there's a lot of real instant
things happening in terms of how we take
code which is a developer as a set of
intents and turn it into running
production systems that developers and
operators can both collaborate on
there's a whole chain of technologies
they're both first party technologies
and third party technologies third party
like spinnaker that we've gotten into
it's an open source project that was
started by Netflix and we've gotten
really involved in it it's a really nice
way to do multi cloud computing and all
of these things really need to come back
to giving developers control of exactly
how they want their code turn
into an artifact like a container how
they want to structure it into services
and pods and where they might want to
run it so I think part of what brought
me to Google was this core belief in
open hybrid cloud when I left Cloud
Foundry I had spent two years you know
committing all of my heartbeats to
putting technology back under the
control of the companies that use it
rather than the companies that sell it
and part of what brought me here was
Brian Stephen said you know our mission
is to be the open cloud I said you must
be kidding me that doesn't make any
sense
every hyperscale cloud providers clearly
and an ambitious monopolist not at all
right so when we look at this we say
like your computation should be where it
wherever it is that's a really hard
problem to solve how do we give you a
control plane that lets you build your
code ever you want deploy it however you
want including to multiple environments
on-premises multiple clouds and then
keep track of how it's all working so
that's really that's soaking up my
attention because I think so many things
are moving fast but better understood
like in infrastructures service which we
do a great job of we're continuing to
add things like tensor processing units
180 teraflops of computes on a single
board which is kind of mind-blowing and
that's just the current generation tank
yeah our platform is a service work
we're doing around App Engine server
lists google kubernetes engine our cloud
services platform those things are all
fascinating better understood and moving
quickly this this slightly you know
maybe we'll use the word inchoate it's
not completely formed right world of I'm
a developer and I'm writing code how do
we make sure that correct code that's
scalable and optimized guest to
production and can be iterated fast by a
distributed diverse inclusive team of
people to make sure that the whole thing
works that's fascinating to me nice do
you remember when you were coding what
you enjoyed the most about writing code
focus just one thing just such a
visceral pleasure right just being able
to sit down and you know as developers I
was doing most of my code in the 90s on
C++ and you know you're working your
brain out right you're working 12 14
hours a day and there's actually a deep
pleasure in in being able to focus
your brain for that much time put on
your headphones put the football on your
computer monitor that says don't
interrupt me because it's neon orange
and everybody's gonna know to leave you
alone whatever those things are and
there's there's a real satisfaction and
getting your brain so deep in something
at the end it compiles runs it works
it's bug free right you've kind of done
the right design work and everything has
come through or you end up with a gnarly
bug and you're like oh my god what the
hell is happening with memory right
these really interesting intellectual
problems you're kind of constantly doing
science on your own work and you're
constantly learning so there's a lot of
things about it but the one thing just
focus if you're a happy programmer it's
because you're focusing and if you're
unhappy it's because product managers
are bothering you all the time it seems
like you you seem quite passionate about
open source which common passion I think
of both of those and probably very many
people here inside Google especially it
does seem to be like a particularly
googly attribute yeah there's a thing
that like just said whatever you happen
to be doing the ethics seem to be around
openness and end-user control and so you
look at YouTube broadcast yourself
open-source is kind of like for
programmers like broadcast yourself go
and borrow yeah but I think it's
interesting to look at the landscape of
open-source like I almost think back you
wanna go back to the 90s well my
shareware I mean like that's even
prettier open-source but like how that
landscape has changed over even the last
ten years I'm sure you have opinions
about things like that about how how how
open-source has really almost become a
corporate thing in many ways it's
interesting there was a meet-up in I
want to say 2006-2007 called the
open-source think tank and there were
you know several dozen open-source
technologists business leaders and one
of the sessions was a challenge a
working session for the whole group to
say what do you want the brand of
open-source to be and I ended up at the
table where one of these folks I won't
name was a respected open-source CEO at
the time he said open-source should
should stand for revolutionary I said I
respectfully completely disagree
every revolution if it's successful
becomes the establishment so that's
where we're at right like you play your
kids Bob Dylan them they're not like oh
man that's so hot and revolutionary
they're like
okay I heard that music growing up sure
so open source I think is it's at that
point on the track like it is the basic
expectation the core licensing model for
developers
the fascinating thing I think that it
represents is actually the shift from
artisanal or a craft level to more
industrial scale use of software if you
look at what's happened in every
industry right the very first machines
built in Industrial Revolution weren't
using standard fasteners standard tools
right you look at the construction
industry people were using bespoke
pieces of wood when you get to
two-by-fours and you get to you know you
know eighth inch precision on the nails
and fasteners you're using you start to
standardize the profession it actually
expands dramatically so I'd see
open-source as being the standardization
even though the standard kind of keep
moving
you're not trying to guess what some
weird proprietary thing is you're like
well of course we're going to use nodejs
right there's a bunch of standards you
can assume that you're going to use in
any case and that enables us to do more
professionalization more
industrialization and I think we'll
probably see over the next couple
decades ten times more developers than
we have today
just as you will see any industry expand
based on better common standards better
understanding what value looks like and
a more predictable path from I have an
idea - I have a result I'm curious to if
you think where things are going if you
know education has been evolving to a
degree do you think that that's gonna
continue to keep shifting and changing
especially in the tech side of things
especially from like a computer science
developer perspective it feels like it
has - I think so much of our education
system now still and I'm not speaking
out of personal knowledge or experience
so maybe I'm being an Internet professor
my wife was a sixth-grade teacher for
about six years so I've learned a bit
from her you know but much of our
current education system was built on
the US Army's insights in the early
1900s about how to sort of induct and
indoctrinate and assess tens or hundreds
of thousands of people at a time and
then to get them to produce predictable
results by standardizing the process
that seems pretty different from the
world we're in today so you know is
education in that style
helping us deal with the world that is
changing faster I don't think it's just
because we're getting older that we feel
like it's going faster measurably it's
getting faster and organizations are
having a harder time adapting to it so a
more adaptive education system that
teaches us how to learn Alvin Toffler
wrote a book in the 1980s called future
shock and there's an outstanding quote
that is crystallized my thinking
he says the illiterate of the future
will not be those who cannot read and
write illiterate of the future will be
those who cannot learn and unlearn so
how are we getting our society ready for
the 21st century by teaching people that
knowledge is actually ephemeral you can
kind of page and page it out it's the
structure of knowing what to know and
how to know it that are the important
skills how are we enabling people to do
that certainly programmers know this
this is something that's been core to
our industry so what do we do to make
ourselves better and what can we learn
from how we've learned to help other
industries make that same leap I'm
curious though as well like that sense
this future like education wise but
technologically wise do you think there
are particular challenges on the horizon
you're talking more about
standardization around technical models
but there could also potentially be
diversification as new things come up
how do you think we're gonna kind of
combat that sort of ebb and flow of that
kind of technology will change boy can
you combat it or can you learn to can
you learn to surf yeah right I think so
much of this is you know make another
personal reference I'm up about a 17
year old Buddhist practice and as you
kind of go through mindfulness and then
you kind of get into what are they
trying to teach you one of the big
things is don't cling it's the clinging
itself to believe that something's
permanent and durable that is going to
cause you suffering so if we can kind of
go well things are going to be in a
constant set of change can we teach
people how to navigate and say actually
the next technology looks like this what
I'd like to see that we need to do to
support human beings in this whether
we're a large software vendor like
Google or if we're you know a tiny
company using that how do you build an
expectation that as companies we take
care of people to learn new things and
to retrain and that we don't expect that
everybody's at 100% efficiency all the
time that we say okay well we'd like you
to be at 50% efficiency for the next
three or
months as you get ready for a leap
forward by learning this new thing
because times have changed this kind of
changing the basic ethics of what
business is to continue education in
work will probably get us into a less
fractious society where we're not
leaving people behind so I tend to think
of the larger scale societal issues as
being more important because the people
who are already in tech are gonna be
fine is there anything in particular
that you found that you've cling to in
the past that you wish you let go of
sooner oh that's a wonderful question I
think probably probably ego and identity
like you know I was thinking Tech
definitely more profound you know just
like you know it's it's it's easy to get
mad about a thing because you're you're
hanging on to the idea and then if you
take another look behind that you're
hanging on to the idea because it was
yours and it means something about you
if it is right or if it's wrong so I
think you know been a strategy
professional for about 15 years and
going from my early days where I was
really bad strategist right I was really
hanging on to the ideas and these days
where I'm you know a less bad strategist
the ideas are a little bit like you know
a Lego block on the table it's not me
it's a Lego block let's talk about the
structure can it be made better let's
attack the ideas to improve them and not
cling to them so though it's kind of a
big professional outcome from letting go
of ego because it allows us to
collaborate better because you're not
offending me when you beat up the idea
you're actually helping me and you know
we're all well benefiting from its
strong opinions weakly held sure and
scientifically right let's actually if
you want to swing back like loose
coupling right for sure yeah it's a
technical perspective yeah
we're to quote a terrible 80s hit hold
on loosely now you're all thinking about
southern rock if you are sure alright
let's swing it swing it back to to
Google that we are the Google cloud
platform podcasters most wonderful yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna throw I'm gonna
throw that the wonderful question if you
had to look into a crystal ball for a
lack of a metaphor that's better five
years ten years in the future where do
you think this cloud stuff is gonna go
like would you see in the in the future
that way I think it's gonna become
obvious that
there's no manifest destiny for cloud
computing just because it happens to be
cloud I think you'll find the computing
is everywhere one analogy that folks
have drawn to computing is electricity
which is broken in a couple ways but the
most important failure of the analogy is
oh hey we have electrical utilities so
you don't need anything else and now
that you have cloud computing you don't
need anything else and to that I say
please go and count the number of
generators in the world right and talk
to Honda about their generator business
it's darn good it turns out there's lots
of reasons for computing to be
everywhere and I don't just mean like
you know on your watch but actually just
like an electrical generator a lot of
reasons for the building to have a
computer right there's locality of
reference there's data there's oh my god
you're on a giant seismographic survey
vessel in the middle of the ocean and
you know you're collecting with really
powerful sensors petabytes a day you
know throw that back to Norway for
processing via satellite most likely not
so we'll find lots and lots of reasons
why computing belongs everywhere and
there's no manifest as I need to pull it
onto the cloud I think that's that's
critical the other thing that's broken
about the the analogy and I admire Nick
car right the end of IT and all of that
stuff was well thought out I think
mostly wrong also because business is
distributed cognition computing and
enables cognition it can't actually be
commoditized in the way that
electricity's been commoditized you want
to be able to continue to move that
boundary so I think as we continue to be
better humans as it we continue to build
better organizations that think better
together we will always find there's
something novel that we continue to seek
so your point about can you really
standardize or do we have to kind of
deal with a little bit mess there I
think it's going to be messy and we'll
tend to avoid pure commoditization and a
classic economic sense for for at least
a decade some of the things that will
push it in that way will be people are
going to have different approaches to
machine learning and automation those
opinions will be strongly held how you
should hold and process the data and how
all that stuff works those will tend to
push against commoditization so a little
off the cloud for a second I curious you
were talking before about letting
ego I'm wondering what you would
recommend or what are some of the key
traits you find make you a successful
leader or make other successful leaders
that you've worked with well whether or
not I'm a successful leader is always
debatable I think we think you're all
right I do think I do think mindfulness
meditation is important you know if you
if you can't let go of thinking it's
hard to know what you think because
you're a little bit more like a shaking
can of soda than a still glass of water
that's super important because it also
lets you kind of be a little calm when
things are triggering one of the things
that comes up in leadership is when a
leader stands up two things happen one
everything that opposes that person's
point of view come into existence that
same moment it's kind of a philosophical
constructs but I've found it to be true
the other thing is you are the top-level
exception handler for the organization
to use a C++ reference so if your day's
going well you're probably getting a
half a dozen escalations that weren't
part of your originally scheduled
routine in some of those they might be
quite but now sometimes they might be
quite fervent so for you to be the one
who's calm when everybody else is
excited is really important right and
it's easiest and less tiring if you're
calm on the inside and then on the
outside you have to become on the
outside that's table stakes
but being uncommon on the inside lets
you kind of get through all of it so I
think just knowing how to relax how to
take a step back and create a safe space
for everybody else to use their natural
human genius which is their intelligence
of how to work through problems that's
the key thing sometimes things will you
know descend into arguments but if you
can just kind of keep opening up a safe
space people will work it out I hope you
feel good at the end they'll be thankful
and you'd be like look you did it
yourself nice thank you well so I think
that probably gets as close to time in
terms of being able to talk with you but
we really appreciate you coming on the
podcast was there anything else that you
wanted to share with us before we before
we go but the best time in history of
the world to be a software developer
isn't now right it's sort of becoming
basic tools and techniques for doing
almost every job over time
I read an article that Rio Tinto one of
the biggest gold mining companies in the
world says that the future software
developer the future miners will be
software developers and they're not
talking about Bitcoin I think talking
about programming the robots that will
go down underground and free humans from
mine collapses and dull dirty and
dangerous work pharmaceutical companies
are saying the future pharmaceutical
discovery is programming so I think this
is just kind of a renaissance for people
who care about producing good outcomes
and like to spend time and focus and
flow building logical expressions of
what ought to get done so you know come
on in the water's great and we'll
continue to try to make it better for
you great well thank you again yeah Sam
thank you so taking the time we really
appreciate you hanging out with us and
having a good chat it's a privilege
thank you so much for having me thanks
Sam that was really great to talk to you
about your background with TCP as well
as here about you know just general
thoughts around leadership and other
areas of technology and your experience
with open source that was kind of cool
actually to hear about his background
especially with Cloud Foundry so mark
let's talk about the question of the
week and as I mentioned the question of
the week is I want to run a Google cloud
function every so many day week whatever
but I can't do cron how do I do that in
cloud functions suite so yes so I'm
fortunate we don't have cron in in cloud
functions right now but there's some
nice workarounds there's a few different
ways I've seen people do this but this
is the one I like the best and it comes
from a friends over at firebase which is
quite nice well we'll link to the github
repository in here but basically the
short answer is this it really requires
two things so App Engine which has
chronic capabilities and pops up there
is a link we'll have in the show notes
that points to github repository but
basically we set up using this code
three different pub subtopics so one for
hourly one for weekly and one for daily
you could obviously change that to be
your own things and then we have cron
within App Engine that just hits those
and pushes something into that topic on
that regular basis that means then that
you can use those for any cloud function
that you want to run on that period
which is quite cool so it's nice and
extensible that's why I like this one
the most because cloud functions have
pub/sub hooks so you can fire off a
cloud function whenever a pub
something gets pushed into it and you
want to react to it and you can have
multiple cloud functions reacting
reacting to the same message you can
have multiple functions reacting to a
single pub/sub topic push seeing their
multiple subscribers so that's a really
nice extensible way to kind of working
around the limitations we have right now
but yet we'll have a link in the show
notes and that's available in github
awesome so I thought I'd throw a
challenge at you this week
we haven't done this in a while
but it's always great when we get
comments and suggestions and feedback
from our audience so I thought we would
go through how people can get in contact
with us from the podcast so I thought
why don't you ask me the questions for
how people can get mark how do we get
into contact with the podcast okay so if
you want to reach out to us obviously
with the websites at JC beat podcast
calm but if you want to send us an email
it's hollow a JCB podcast you can add us
on Twitter
GCE podcast you will see that each post
has both Reddit and Google+ links so if
you want to find it's on Google+ it's
plus JCB podcast on reddit its /r GCB
podcast you can reach out to us directly
on the hash podcast channel on the
Google cloud platform community slack
which you can find a bit Dudley /g CP -
slack Wow
nice there you had that all in your
memory yes I met a few times a little
bit all right well that's it I think for
us for this week mark you're gonna be
anywhere no I'm still just wrapping
stuff up and getting stuff ready for
Game Developers Conference in March how
about yourself you're off to London soon
aren't you yes I'm gonna be speaking at
the AI Congress and talking about AI and
enterprise and on January 30th awesome
yeah and just a note for the listeners
that we are not going to be having to
podcast this week that was definitely a
unique thing for last week but we will
definitely have another one in the
following weeks so what we got
awesome well Melanie thank you so much
for joining me yet another week on the
podcast thanks mark awesome and thank
you to all for listening and we'll see
you all next week
you